hold on there partners before we get
this show started we got a real special
announcement from down here in aunt
doody's basement
uncle hank and kippy a couple of city
slickers are going to be heading out
down south
we're going to be at raleigh good nights
in north carolina april 20th
it's coming up the next night we're
gonna be in zany's nashville
so get some ticks yeah guys it's gonna
be a good time we're gonna be doing some
live stand-up
t-bones coming with us and then we're
gonna be doing
uh some live ayg with you guys you guys
are gonna give us questions we're gonna
be asking you questions
uh so grab some friends come on out it's
gonna be fun we're gonna be [ __ ] on
your stupid uncle ted or whoever comes
your buddies
your buddy steve who's an [ __ ] it's
gonna be a good time come correct don't
be showing up with sneaks and no socks
on
we're gonna rip on you we're gonna we're
gonna be having some beers we're gonna
be taking some pics we're gonna be
hanging out
we'll see you there now let's get the
show started
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's favorite new
podcast
this is ru garbage a show we sit down
with our guests to determine whether
they grow up to be classy
or if they're just a big old piece of
trash i'm your host stage foley coming
at you on a beautiful day
we're down here at aunt toddy's basement
she is not here
no i had the i put her on on a casino
bus
i got her out of town if she knew he was
coming in
yeah there'd be panties getting thrown
at the guy it'd be extra large panties
getting thrown at the guy i couldn't
even have it
i didn't want to embarrass this so she's
down at the regatta for the weekend on
our dime
put it on your credit card so we got
that out of the way
my co-host is coming at you from right
next to me he is the ceo of ru garbage
he's really an international businessman
when
when when you get right down to it he's
got his toes in a lot of pools around
the
around the globe sure kevin james ryan
everybody hey gang thanks for tuning in
as always please make sure you rate
review subscribe on itunes uh full video
available on youtube those numbers are
[ __ ] true to rooftop
through the roof through the roof and
also patreon.com
are you garbage you can sign up you can
get bonus episodes of ayg
episodes of hard feelings and we do a
live stream every month with the top
tier members
it's a good time oh yeah check it out
gang and how about a nice shout out to
our producer extraordinaire
the magic man he keeps us looking good
give it up for t-bone mcmuffin
toby mcmullen everybody what up boys we
got a hot one we got a real life [ __ ]
star legend in the building i know
i'm so excited and nervous at the same
time we vacuumed before he got here if
that says anything we [ __ ] vacuum the
studio before he got here from star
power
gang we could not be more excited to
have our incredibly incredibly
incredibly special guest here with us
today academy award nominated
not the usual bums we have walking
through this dump
all right this gentleman has appeared as
an actor in 78 films and television
shows
some to mention would be of course a
bronx tale
bullets over broadway the usual suspects
mulholland falls
hurley burley i at the roxbury analyzed
this stuart little down the earth
running scared a guide to recognizing
your saints
modern family he's going to be in the
new law and order organized crime and
he's going to be in the godfather of
harlem coming out
okay he also owns multiple restaurants
he has his own show called the chas palm
and terry show
ladies and gentlemen he's got five
fingers but he only uses three
give it the [ __ ] up for the one the only
mr chas palm and terry uh dice fools
you guys are all right thanks for coming
in that's it that's the show
you know i love the show i watch it you
know i do
and i just laughed because you know i
grew up in a lot of garbage
so i said are you going i said what a
great show that is so thanks for having
me well the way
the way we look at it all right now of
course you know everybody wants to know
are you garbage if you are i'm not going
to say it
all right but i guarantee you're not so
we're kind of looking at you as more of
a barometer
of a class yeah well i appreciate that
yeah you're a very classy guy you carry
yourself
very well nice you know what i mean very
well put together all the time i don't
know too many people that look better in
a suit than you
uh i wear suits a lot
but i get this feeling every time i put
on a suit i feel like i want to slap
somebody
before you got here i said that when he
slapped someone in a suit
nobody else looks as good as him
slapping somebody as i put on a suit
people go
i i get nervous i think you're going to
slap me yeah yeah well i can always feel
you like yeah like tightening the cover
on bottom i'm like you should have your
own version of cameo
where people hire you to smack people
around like somebody's birthday
you gimmel you put on the suit and you
give him a little bit of a smack
no i gotta be honest with you i'm i'm
legend for i do uh
i teach master classes uh-huh and i'm
legend for not
women of course men i'm led you for if
an actor can't get the right
mood or you can't do it i say look is it
all right if i
do whatever i want to do give me a smack
i'm legend for smackdown
that's true i don't know i 100 believe
it or not i smack with the best of my
hand to god i'm not kidding
we believe you i'll smack him and i say
and he'll go i'll go all right now do
this
i go now do the scene again come on bam
[Laughter]
you know in bronx tale that scene with
lilo and i'm smacking him
in that scene when he's up you know he
couldn't get it you know and i turned to
dinero and i said bob you know we
we filmed like four or five takes i said
he's still not there yet so bob says
i said bob i got to do what i got to do
he goes what's that i go let me let me
just do it he says all right do whatever
you got to do
and i said come on bam and he went i
went come on bam
bam and he was like oh are you bam i
said never mind why just say the [ __ ]
words
we're 20 minutes over lunch let's go and
because i said bob just keep filming
they kept filming i just say the [ __ ]
he was a sonny and i'm sorry he said
he started anything but that was joni
wade
you know he was young you know he's
young actor yeah and he's a terrific
actor but sometimes you've got to get
you know you got to get a little rough
with it you know what i mean
that's funny to think if you're telling
de niro today hey let's go take a walk i
got a straight no
no no no i didn't say that i just said
the bomb said do what you got to do and
i said okay
here we go yeah you're also one of the
very few people in show business can
call de niro bob
yeah and it's so you're the only one
that can do it yeah
everybody else is trying to be like you
when they here's the deal
people who really of bob's friend call
him bob
yeah people who are his family
call him robert people that claim to
know him but don't know him call him
bobby yeah
so whenever you give away whenever
you're somebody go hey tell bobby i
shuttle up he don't [ __ ]
you don't [ __ ] know him hey you know
me and me and bobby we grew up together
yeah
get out of here bobby you know
they don't [ __ ] know him some 25 year
old says that yeah we grew up together
yeah exactly i i had always
thought and that's why like uh you know
your upbringing is well documented like
we said
yeah i'm curious about the years right
before bronxdale because i had thought
just you know naturally when i was
younger that it was like you came up
with like de niro
and pesci i studied i was 10 years
younger than that right
okay so they're older than i am when i
was at the actor's studio don't forget
al and those guys were 10 years they
were ahead of me
so i was always behind them you know but
uh
i i i started in films 30 something
years ago so i
i made a lot of movies with al with uh
with bob i made four movies with bob so
people do put us together yeah but i was
10 years i'm 10 years
younger than those guys and you were
like you were like a proper like
struggling working actor yes
before a garage sale yeah i had a
broadway credits before
that but i you know that doesn't mean
anything when you go to hollywood
yeah [ __ ] about that you know you got to
have you got to be a star you got to be
somebody
right you know that's the way it was so
sorry you know it's okay
that's crazy so that that was the whole
thing that i want to focus on so you
were in new york city as like a working
actor
oh yeah i was i was well you were a
little bit older i was older yeah i mean
i didn't make it till i was uh
well i i i was 39 when i made it you
know when bronx tale hit well brock
still hit yeah
and you did that on your own right yeah
i mean i'll tell you the whole i'll tell
you
i'll try to make the story yeah
i was working uh as an actor going on
but then i also worked as a doorman at a
club 1982 called the limelight
right if you guys are too young i think
i might have worked with somebody that
my
brother knows a friend of our family guy
named phil frack phil fracazzini you
remember a guy named phil fracazzini
that name sounds familiar okay it was
just cutting that that's him being nice
yeah he knows bobby right out
[Applause]
[Laughter]
i wanted to i went to a restaurant once
this guy goes chaz
throws his [ __ ] arms around right and
my wife is standing right
here and the first thing he says he goes
how's your mom and dad
so that threw me i said oh [ __ ] he must
be a family
i go yeah this is my wife oh how are you
he goes and he turns to the
people of the table he goes we grew up
together me in the sky right
me and this guy were like best friends
right and i saw he goes he goes you know
my cousin he sold that corvette he kept
for years i went
really how much you get from him
he takes the kelly blue book he tells me
i go whoa oh i finally made him
i'm talking about his cousin i don't
know who the [ __ ] this guy
is i walk away my wife goes who is that
i go honey i have no idea
well we're going away next weekend with
them pack the bags
but you're you're right you know you
just be nice yeah yeah yeah yeah of
course
i thought that was going to be
guaranteed from from how much pushback i
got from my family but i'm telling you
he knows him he knows him he knows him
don't make me look better say i know i
mean you know what
it's it's 35 40. i mean it's hard of
course
yeah you know people go chaz you know i
get people come up with me
you do a broadway show you walk out you
sign order guys right i come out and the
guy goes
jazz jazz i go yeah he goes
what you don't remember me i go
uh i'm sorry he goes brother daggett's
class eighth grade
[Laughter]
like excuse me it was yesterday if
you're a hundred pounds more
no [ __ ] hair yeah you're not little
timmy anymore okay
exactly yeah no anyway okay i i go on
these rants no
we love it but it's also that just
thought like everybody once you get
famous everybody goes i know
of course you're not going i know timmy
from saint bobby's
yeah you know what i mean everybody
remembers you you don't [ __ ] remember
everybody else
chaz it's me oh my god timmy look at me
timmy look at you
you still [ __ ] driving a bus
so i was in uh in new york working as a
as a doorman bodyguard for this guy
pedigation who owned the limelight
because i used to box you know my father
was a professional are you a big guy
bigger guy or just
yeah no i was i mean yeah how i am what
you want to
[Laughter]
you know you just met me you're not my
[ __ ] friend
so anyway no so i was worried about his
body you know
guys you know boxing whatever so what
happened was
he finally said hey you know i want you
to run this club in new jers
chicago and i said no i want to go to la
and try my luck there
so i said he went you offered me like a
lot of money to manage this club plus i
haven't bring a car
i said no find me so i could go to la
and collect unemployment
this is how nice i was i went to la i
like you as i got that boom
i got a hill street blues a couple of
those shows that i broke down a couple
of those sushi blues madelock dallas
right a couple of peter gunner mini
series and i was doing okay
you know okay okay yeah but then i ran
out of money again like in
about two years later i was holding that
money and i ran out of that we all know
the deal
we're going through it right now so i
said well i'll start working as a door
again
you know as a you know doorman so i
worked at this real swanky club and i
was doing well there
to supplement my income as it was
auditioning and then one day
i'm at the door now there's three things
you can never do
to a bouncer three things you'll never
get in the club if you do
and if you do one of these three things
if you
here are the three things guys the first
thing is
you never say the words do you know who
i am of course
yeah of course you're done you say that
to a guy in the door [ __ ] you you're not
getting it
what i always say is yeah i if i knew
who you are you'd be on the [ __ ] list
you know you know he'd be in there
dancing right guess what
the second thing is you never grab the
rope never like grab the velvet rope
yeah that's like that
yeah and the third thing is you never
get into space
in the doorman's face this guy walks
over grabs the rope
gets in my face and says do you know who
i am
he broke all three rules
so i broke all three ribs because he
said i'm late
don't you know and i said i'm sorry so
yeah i so then i said something really
smart and
he goes i'm telling you do you know who
i am then i finally said yes
you're the guy who's not getting into it
i love it i love it so he looked at me
and said you'll be fine in 15 minutes
what that's what he said to me i'll
never forget it he made a big ruckus
people went inside they called the boss
the boss came out and went swifty
and i went swiftly and i heard i heard
the name swifty
it was swifty lazar now you guys are too
young swifty lazar
was the biggest agent in the world in
entertainment
in the world and i me an actor just told
he looks at me 15 minutes later i'm
fired
fired the boy said i love you man i love
you charles but he has
he goes that was his party you were
keeping him out of his own party
i said oh [ __ ] so i said look you've
been good to me i said to the owner
it's okay don't worry about it i got it
back into my 1972 honda civic with a
[ __ ]
dent in it with the water leaking i got
back to my [ __ ] apartment
i got into the i sat down there at the
edge of my bed i see
i saw this little thing it said the
saddest thing in life is wasted talent
it's a car that my father gave me and
he's the one who said that my dad
i looked at that and i said you know
what if they won't give me a [ __ ]
pot i write one myself so i went to
thrifty drugstore ventura boulevard at
that time i got five tabs of yellow
paper
and i started said what am i gonna write
about i said i'll write about the
killing that i saw
when i was nine because i always thought
about it i said and i'll talk about my
father
and sonny the wise guy and how the
difference
influenced me growing up so i wrote like
five minutes
about five minutes of it and that monday
i got fired on a saturday that monday i
performed it on
at my theater workshop so i did exactly
what you guys do it comedians
what i put i got up there and i started
doing the monologue
and acting some of the scenes and out of
the five minutes
i kept three minutes and then i wrote
during the week another 10 minutes that
at that 10 minutes
i kept four more minutes and i did that
for a year
jesus so at the end of almost a year i
had 90 minutes
of [ __ ] that worked yeah you know yeah
yeah yeah when you process
the process right so i said [ __ ] i got
90 i got
i got this one man show i said i said it
i i but i never
did it at all it's an entirety yet like
together i did 40 minutes 20 minutes
and finally i said i got to produce this
thing so i called my friend peter
gesheno
and i said peter i always wanted to be
in business i said
uh could you send me some would you like
to invest in a play
i go it's not a movie i know you want to
be in movies but this is a play he goes
let me think about it
i said okay next day knock on my door i
opened the [ __ ] door
this guy's standing there goes you
charged back i go yeah sign here
i sign there he gives me a uh fedex
and i open it up and there's like forty
thousand dollars
damn in cash or a check no no no okay i
was like what the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i said you didn't even read it you
didn't even know what he goes you know i
saw you in a couple of plays and
i believe in you you got time yeah
that's awesome it's amazing i get the 40
000. i
so i produced the play myself i put it
up
[ __ ] bam my [ __ ] career just [ __ ]
exploded
there was a guy they were talking about
it so much a guy from the la times went
to see it
and he just raved about it you know it's
one of those reviews your mother would
write yeah
yeah yeah yeah incredible genius
whatever whatever you know he said these
incredible things
never been done before it is a one-man
show see i did a linear story i just
didn't drink water and didn't do an
act i did a movie on stage by myself
and so everybody was coming to see it
nicholson came pacino
came every director came every producer
came are you [ __ ] your pants at that
point when you're they're like when
they're like deniro's out there
he wasn't there at 60c theater we had to
move to a 300 seat theater with so many
people
still i was selling out they offered me
i get a phone call at my house in my
dumpy apartment
two hundred fifty thousand dollars from
the uh first
studio that i called i got 200 in the
bank not in cash
250 000. so i said well yeah but i want
to play sonny and i want to write the
excuse
they said look guy you're great you're
terrified
let the professionals take over from
yeah it's like heisman
yeah yeah so we want we want a number
one guy to write the screenplay we just
want to buy your story i said no it's my
[ __ ] life
i say no three weeks later
five hundred thousand they called back
i got 200 in the bank no money
500 000. play selling out but the money
that i'm getting i'm paying peter back
sure and i'm paying
my people there right right i'm making
no money
finally i signed with the william mars
at the time
and i signed with them great agency
fantastic agency as a matter of fact
shout out shout out to william let me
tell you something about william
i'll tell you icm caa
and william mars were all after me
chasing me a week before bronx tale i
couldn't i wasn't allowed on the block
okay now they're all chasing me so
finally i call up william morris
and i say look i said i can't uh
this is before while this is going on i
called him up i said look i can't make
the meeting today
i have to this is a side story they say
why can't you make it what happened
you signing with somebody else i said no
no my car is overheating
because i had a hole in the radiator and
it was slowly overheating
72 honda 7200 it's working that's like
yeah it's like the hollywood store
it's working comic shape exactly so they
go
uh stay right there don't move we'll get
right back to you i'm like
what the [ __ ] was that about leeco when
i tell you my age
lee cohen fred westheimer [ __ ] great
guys man
they [ __ ] i always i get a knock on
the door i open the door
the guy goes you charge bobby
i got another 40k what's going on i'm
excited right
every time every time i see these guys
something happens
he goes come with me i go where you
going he goes come with me
i go downstairs i go into the [ __ ]
parking lot
now you remember you know i'm with all
broke actors
comics right he goes i look and i see a
1989
brand new cadillac el dorado black
black saddle interior gorgeous he goes
here's your keys william mars got this
for you don't be late for the meeting
damn new paddy holy [ __ ]
are you [ __ ] i'm like what what what i'm
not my
car's right next to the cat like smoking
so so this this girl
comes over to me smoking this girl goes
on and she goes chaz
holy [ __ ] everybody's coming out all
this time all these perks
people are coming out hey i said no i
just got this car
so she goes on i need a car she goes can
i have this one
i said well i yeah she knows how much
you want for it i said
uh how much you got she goes 40 bucks i
go good
[Laughter]
sold the coffee for forty dollars
right got in the [ __ ] but then i
called him i said hey man i didn't
decide to sign with you guys yet
they said that's all right we leased the
car for two years if you sign with us
great if not it's yours
let's face it gang spending time with
the post office is not really a whole
lot of fun for anybody
no way that's why we recommend mailing
and shipping online with stamps.com
stamps.com allows you to mail and ship
anytime
anywhere right from your computer you
can send letters ship packages
it would all be pay a lot less with
discounted rates from usps and ups
and more stamps.com has saved businesses
thousands of hours and
tons and tons of money with stamps.com
you get the service
of the post office and ups all in one
place plus big discounts on mailing and
shipping rates all that money baby
we use it here at ru garbage all the
cards that we ship out all the merch
it's all stamps.com baby it's easy they
send you a package they give you some
free postage they give you a scale
you get the you get the printer it's
real easy uh
we do it you just hook it up to your uh
computer print them out stick them on
throw and go you can organize a pickup
for them to come get it
knocks right through it man it's easy
peasy yeah it's awesome guys
um so wisdams.com you get 40
uh off post office rates and 62 percent
of ups shipping rates
not to mention stamps.com is a fraction
of the cost of those expensive postage
meters
what yeah baby stamps.com is a
no-brainer
saves you time and money it's no wonder
there's nearly one million businesses
that already
take advantage of stamps that's a lot
all you need is a computer
wi-fi and the printer baby it's easy
peasy so stop wasting time
by going to the post office and go to
stamps.com instead there's no risk and
with our promo code garbage
you'll get the special offer that
includes a four-week trial plus free
postage and digital scale
no long-term commitment or contracts
baby
throw it and go uh just go to stamps.com
click the microphone at the top of the
homepage
type in garbage stamps.com never go to
the post office again
use promo code garbage gang you see what
i got in my hand right here you see this
right here
this is fume baby pretty cool fume took
a look at the world and noticed that the
solutions for quitting smoking like
patches and nicotine
inhalers were neither desirable nor
fun nor worked they stink they stink the
gum
rips up your mouth it's horrible it's
terrible so in response fume handcrafted
beautiful wooden pipes to make
the quitting smoking process simple easy
and
even desirable because it smells and
tastes absolutely fantastic
it isn't a vape nope it doesn't use
nicotine but instead he uses cores and
fuse with the world super plants
that are known to help successfully quit
smoking from start
to finish yeah uh it's really easy to
take the core throw it right down a
little tube there and you can hit away
baby
so head to breathefume.com that's b r e
a t h e fume fume.com
and use our promo code garbage and grab
a fume and check out the variety of
plant infused cores to start
today their conquer cure their conquer
core is the number one core for quitting
smoking from start to finish
take it they sent us three of them we've
been cranking fantastic um
it's really easy fume has already helped
over 30 000 customers worldwide
with hundreds of customers who have
shared their quitting stories on their
site you can go there
and check it out so head to
www.breathefume.com
that's b-r-e-a-t-h-e
fume f-u-m and use promo code garbage
save yourself 10 percent and help you or
a loved one quit smoking today
gang after years of fine print contracts
and getting ripped off by the big
wireless providers if we've learned
anything
it's that there's always a catch they
get you coming and going
they get you coming and going you think
you're getting one thing you're really
getting another and it's not in your
favor
nope so when we first heard about mint
mobile
okay and that they offer premium
wireless service
starting at 15 a month
we thought to ourselves there's got to
be a catch there's no way this can be
true
but after speaking with them and using
their service
it all makes sense yeah guys uh i've
actually
my wife has been using mint mobile for
like two years before using before the
podcast
crazy she's it's crazy that they signed
on to be a sponsor it's really easy it
literally sounds too good to be true
it's 15 bucks you get unlimited talk
unlimited text
nations 5g network the whole [ __ ] bang
you use your own phone
you usually you keep your number no
trading numbers no trading they don't
give you like a little crappy phone or
something like that
it's not a flip phone you're not using
your iphone 15 bucks a month 15 dude i'm
telling you i thought it was too good to
be true i found it a couple of years ago
as an option when she came here i was
like oh here's a us number you can use
bada bing bada boom sure
and she just keeps re-upping because
it's it's just like yeah
it makes why are you gonna sign if you
don't have to you know what i mean
so if you're in the market and you're
looking around it's easy peasy guys
uh get your new wireless pan for just 15
bucks a month
and get the pl and get the plan shipped
to your door for free
go to mintmobile.com garbage that's mint
mobile m i t
m i n t m o b i l
e dot com slash garbage and cut your
wireless bill to
15 clams a month crazy at mintmobile.com
garbage now back to the show
damn this is how bad this how crazy it
was it's not so worth it i signed with
them
jesus christ so anyway get back to the
thing everybody's coming everybody's
coming so finally i sign with them they
say
we got another meeting to go to i said
all right they take me to this other
meeting
big studio guy has a piece of paper
right here we sit down
12 people sitting down let's forget it
got a piece of paper he's holding the
paper he
slides it over to me goes chaz we know
what's going on in hollywood
everybody wants this we'll tell you
something right now if you sign that
paper
you'll have a check tomorrow for one
million dollars ah
i'm sweating right now i'm thinking
about that what do i say the first thing
out of my mouth
i say is there a bathroom here
[Laughter]
so he goes yeah there's the executive
bathroom right there they give me the
key i walk over i walk out i go into
this beautiful executive bedroom and i'm
by myself in there
i'm taking deep breaths a billion
dollars right 200 in a bank i could help
my mother father who never had money
right yeah i could help them i could
really of course it's not just for you
anymore i'm not married i'm single so it
was okay
so finally i i look at the thing i put
my hand in my pocket and for some reason
i put my
the card with me and i don't know why i
took the card sales taking life is
wasted
right so i put it back i look at it i go
i wash my hands
wash my face i look in the mirror and i
go [ __ ] it
and i walk back out and i say to them i
said look
i'll sign that paper and i can see
they're all like oh god
i said but i play sonny and i write the
screenplay
and the guy just went like this ah he
said chaz
jazz [ __ ] we can't make a movie with you
in it you're a wonderful actor but
nobody knows you
he goes we can't make a movie we have to
make it with a star
we can't make it with you and i said
well i'm sorry
i said i can't do it so i said that
meeting's over i guess i stood up
like two weeks god i'm not gonna
hyperventilate my two agents are looking
at me like what the
[ __ ] give us give us the car back this
guy's [ __ ] quick
yeah he just cost me 100k what the [ __ ]
jazz guys thank you so i stood up i
stood up
and they said they walked out with me no
as i'm walking out the
the guy goes out of the studio says hey
chaz you know
uh this movie won't get made just like
that
i said you're right it won't with you
but it will get made and he goes what
makes you so sure i said because it's
too
[ __ ] good nice
that's what i said i love it that's what
i said i'll never forget it my hand to
god
and i walked out with my agents they're
looking at me like this [ __ ] guys
he's nuts yeah right i started doing the
show again the crowds kept coming
all these big producers kept coming burt
reynolds came ray shocking
everybody they all wanted to play sonny
and all these big writer directors
wanted to direct it
finally i'm there and i get off the
stage
and all of a sudden they say to me
robert de niro's in the dressing room
he just saw the show he's waiting for
you oh [ __ ] i'm in the room
in the dressing room he's waiting for
him you're addressing soon as i got on
stage they said he
he left he left right when they started
clapping and snuck in and got into my
dressing room
and i said but i said deniro was in the
dressing room he said yeah
have him
[Laughter]
you know the way he does it and he goes
uh that's the [ __ ]
that's the greatest one-man show i ever
saw he goes that's a movie you did a
movie
i go yeah he goes how'd you do that you
know he was really very happy
so he goes listen i'll tell you what i
want to do this is how [ __ ] nuts i
was
i said i know what you're going to say i
said but i just want to know he goes i
know what you're going to say
i know i know do you know for 45 minutes
i'll tell you how i
if you sell it they're going to come to
me anyway he goes and i know you don't
want to sell crazy yeah so he says but
if you he goes you play he goes you'll
be great at sonny right and you write it
because it's your life it'll be honest
he goes i'll play your father and i'll
direct it
and we'll go partners and if you shake
my hands that's the way it'll be
i shook his hand that's how it happened
oh damn if you shake my hand
that's the way it'll be man that's some
cold [ __ ] right there yes
that's fantastic yeah that's and that's
what happened so that solved the
problems of like
saying that they needed to have like a
star attached to it to sell because
he was playing my father yeah he said
i'll play your father you play sonny and
i'll direct it
so there was the star power right right
now then he can well he can go like this
is what we're doing
exactly wow and as soon as he's he came
on board and signed
the studio went chaz is going to be
great chad
chad i wanted you for this the whole
time it'll be better it'll be honest
was it not the same was it real was it
the same studio
that you had the meeting with a million
dollars different different studio yeah
yeah
holy [ __ ] can you imagine that dude it's
insane dude i was i i was nervous that
whole entire time he was telling this
i know it worked out well and i'm like
i'm still like oh what happened this is
after
now this is after i got the deal right
one other studio guy heads come over he
goes
gonna be great with you this is one of
the guys right listen
see i'm i've been in hollywood 40 years
he goes you know why i love your writing
chance
he knows he's going like this
he's putting it in my face like he goes
you're writing it's this
it's i go i'm sitting there trying to
keep a straight finger
i want to tell the guy to go [ __ ]
himself you know what this is chaz it's
dirt
he goes your writing is full of dirt
it's real
he goes it's not like he goes you ever
see a souffle it looks beautiful you
open it up get a fork
put a hole in it got nothing inside
and i'm saying to myself is this [ __ ]
guy serious this guy's got a half an
eight ball
[Laughter]
your writing is great i'm saying myself
okay yeah i appreciate that
meanwhile until de niro came there was
no [ __ ] way i was doing this
right i mean sort of later i think
something would happen because i
wouldn't sell it
but that's that's uh you know that was
the deal man that's insane
that's a wild [ __ ] story i know and
like you said you weren't yeah i mean
you were you're 39
39 39 39 years old no money in the bank
no health insurance nothing nothing
but i said [ __ ] it so what you what year
exactly was that
1989. so this is 89. so then the movies
the movies shot and what you shot it was
not shot at night i had to wait
we had to wait for well i came to new
york then in 90 to do the play again in
look and it was a big hit here to do it
on broadway no off-road
the first time was off-broadway okay and
uh bob just said look
i want to do it but i have these movies
lined up you know you get the narrow
that's the only bad thing you got to
wait
you know he's not going from job to job
this is 1989 that you had that you had
this encounter with de niro 1989 so a
good fella still hasn't even come out
yet no
good fellows hasn't come out yet holy
[ __ ] nothing that's
right i got these other couple of things
i got to do
yeah it's a good fellow and it was a
whole bunch of things he had to do
but he said i give you my word we're
doing this damn so i just did other
things you know
you know i did oscar with stallone and i
kept uh
doing some i did i got a mini series you
know it was good
but but then after the [ __ ] bronx
tail hit
i mean that's a [ __ ] game pictures
now bronx tale
bam [ __ ] explodes usual suspect is
next
academy award nomination that's what i'm
saying i've been on a [ __ ] i've been
like
i've been in the zone for 30 years yeah
yeah you know what i'm saying so that
was like my big break
yeah it was crazy that's that's the
thing that i wanted to say was nuts so
93
the bronze set comes out less than two
years later academy award nominated
right
it's [ __ ] insane you're insane yeah
crazy that's yeah it's not wild [ __ ]
story inspiring story
tell swifty whatever his name is the
[ __ ] hit the break
right well he died not too loud after
that
[Laughter]
i never got a chance to say thank you
[Laughter]
you know no but he you know he was an
[ __ ] i have to say it was he was
nasty and he was an [ __ ] and he
he got me fine but you know what it was
the best thing that ever happened
yeah is there any celebrities that you
had the you know when you were working
though that you had like straighten out
or
or you know not let them in or anything
like that were they acting like [ __ ]
yeah but i don't yeah okay you're gonna
make a strategy
you're not gonna make [ __ ] challenges
what the [ __ ]
there was a celebrity i'll tell you the
story but i really see that yeah yeah i
didn't think he was gonna start
but i will tell you the story i won't
tell you who it was there was a thing
where this guy was on broadway
very famous actor and i'm working the
door in 1982
and he comes over to me and he and it's
really cool and i had this big kamali
coat on
with a scarf and i'm standing there like
this you know and
he starts yelling at the [ __ ] i think
he was like i don't want to say
he was like coked up yeah drunk he was
drunk
and he starts yelling at the the doorman
who's really a sweet guy you know nice
guy
and he starts yelling at him [ __ ] put
his finger in his face and i said hey
hey take it easy
and he said and who the [ __ ] you think
you are
with your scarf and your coat i said who
am i
trying to guess i grabbed him by the
[ __ ] car
i put him up i said i'm gonna dent your
[ __ ] chest
two bounces and they dragged me they
held me
and they said do you know who that is
and i went oh [ __ ]
and yeah but then they straightened it
up yeah chad's not good with faces and
names
but then five years later
i'm at a big event in a tuxedo and who
[ __ ] sits right next to me
he does does he does he reckon that
probably not yeah no i never said a word
he was on the moon at that time measure
that i told my wife
she goes don't say a word i said oh he
doesn't know
i said first of all he was so [ __ ]
yeah that wasn't probably if he's if
he's doing that
that doesn't happen just one time
together i realize i shouldn't say that
story if i'm not going to say who it was
that don't matter i'm not going to say
always but that's yeah i shouldn't have
said that i just want to hear a story
about you smacking somebody around
yeah that's all i really cared about let
me tell you
i had a [ __ ] story i could tell you
my bouncer stories it's a quarter of
four
right i'm there and all of a sudden at
which we close at four o'clock but this
is the this is the limelight
this is this is this this is the height
of it it's the height this is the eight
this is like stupid that's the height of
club it was studio 54
live yeah yeah yeah so i'm there and
also it's a quarter of four it's 20
to get in so
now i got i got to be politically
corrected here there's still little
people
okay come there's little people yeah you
know do they
it's incorrect say [ __ ] i guess it is
they're little yeah i think little
people like little people they like
little people
so they're very they were nice they come
up she she has a gown on and he's got
like a tux up
and they come walking over to me and you
know i'm cool you know any guy goes
uh two please how much is that i go i
said you know what it's
it's quarter to four i said we're not
letting anybody in yeah we're closed i
said there's no sense to let you
are you he goes are you racist uh are
you
prejudiced against little people you're
embarrassed that we and he starts
[ __ ] yelling at me
and i'm saying no so you you're wrong
i'm six foot for [ __ ] four you know
you're wrong i said it's just that it's
a quarter to four
we're not letting anybody in we're not
letting anybody i don't want you to pay
twenty dollars
ten minutes i i don't we're closing ten
fifteen minutes no i don't
i'll kick your [ __ ] ass i said what
i wanted to pick him up like a spalding
so i said you know what fine i said okay
you got your way charge them half price
yeah i just met charge them here
price yeah yeah he thought i took it as
an insult he took it a cushion was small
charge us here he goes y'all make it
because all the bouncers started
laughing when i said that
you're making fun of us charge me half
price i'm a man i'm like
holy [ __ ] no i was trying to give you a
break a price i'm trying to give him a
break now i'm saying to myself
i'm gonna lose lose yeah if i kick his
ass that's bad
it kicks your ass it's even worse
[Laughter]
we're really enjoying bad shape bobby's
out if you get your ass kicked
if he [ __ ] me out i'm in trouble so
i just shut my mouth and they walked out
oh that's [ __ ] great
holy [ __ ] all right all right let's
switch gears let's get into some
questions let's play some ru garbage
all right so we're going to ask you a
series of questions determine whether
you're trashy or not
we know you're not going to be yeah i
mean this guy's all class all classes
all right good
uh you want to take it take the lead
there big guy uh yeah so we're gonna
kind of we're gonna
kind of start with you know with now
where you're living now in a situation
right there what's the name of the
grocery store that you go to
that i go to now yeah or do you go to
the grocery store
uh yeah it's uh i go to this place
called the uh
bedford gourmet oh that's [ __ ] nice
i've never heard of it but it sounds
[ __ ] classy
that ain't a discount place i'll tell
you that much oh god you said that like
you said that was like a hideout or
something like that no when you go there
you got to get a co-sign on it
i can smell the bread from here dude
yeah classy play that sounds these are
the things we're curious about i go
there and i go to gristiti's
you do so you you go yourself what's it
well yeah
normally who would go my wife goes or
you know
just somebody of the healthcare that
works around the world yeah i hope that
works well
but i could see you at a gristiti's no
question no question
yes yelling at the bad boy or something
i said the eggs on the top all right
kippy um all right at your house now
currently did you
do you guys wear your shoes in the house
oh well i i don't know we
some some my wife does i don't know i
like to take my shoes off
yeah that's the way to do it is there is
it a rule like if we came to the house
no you're just getting your shoes on i
don't like i don't like that you got to
take your shoes off i don't like telling
people that yeah there's a
nice rug outside your wife it is fine
yeah yeah
well you take your shoes off if you go
to someone else's house if you go for
dinner and they're like hey we're a
shoes off family are you going what the
[ __ ]
i i i i take it off because if i'm
having dinner at the house probably i'm
never going to be there again
i'll do it that one yeah i'll do that
one time i'll appease you this time
alopecia this time
yeah i'll do that one time so yeah i try
to be
nice about that uh where do you get your
hair cut now
uh at home they do it at that they come
to the house this morning that's the
classiest way
no it's class right what do you tip on a
haircut
well she comes i just give her she just
give her whatever though
you know she just charges me uh it's
like a private thing she comes
she shows the salon comes to my house
and i pay you and she gets paid very
well very well
because when she cuts my hair she does
my wife everybody gets the whole yeah
if my
by far and away i have never i have
never been to a barber probably
where people are no about 30 years
always they come to the house
always come to the house see we've got
to get on that that's cool we got to get
somebody coming here come on oh that'd
be nice
yeah come in here yeah we can do that
you could do that yeah you could do that
man
are you a toaster family or a toaster
oven family
do you have a toaster oven or a toaster
in the house we have both
yeah both it's pretty good it's [ __ ]
good this guy's all glass sometimes you
keep the toaster out or do you put it
away
after you get done the toaster is out
toasters out when you say the toaster
oven no we have a
confection oven which is a microwave and
oven which is on top
oh yeah yeah it's classy it's you can't
afford it let's leave it at that
you don't have to worry about that until
we make something what's the oven is it
a viking
it is yes how about the fridge subzee
yes oh
stainless steel yes oh stainless steel
skin
yes no it's aluminum siding
goddammit kippy sub season viking yeah
guys [ __ ] we're dude we're sitting
here with jazz
guys but let me let me be clear i i i
didn't grow up with this
no yeah no we know we know that's why we
love it oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah 32 one bedroom and [ __ ] that way
yeah driving the [ __ ]
exactly there's 32 honda we don't know
that's also what we celebrate when we do
have people on
earth are making money at some point
struggled so long yes now you get to
reap the benefits of
working you know for 30 40 struggling
yeah we're not the irs
yeah i got an oven i'm not looking for
receipts chad oh yeah i got enough of it
it's not that expensive
it's in the driveway it's weird i'm
hoping things turn around
oh that's fantastic what about in the
garage in the garage
do you have a refrigerator in that
garage yes
yeah you do huh yes and inside you got
sodas and all that stuff
yes big thing on the podcast is the
garage garage breaking garage fridge
yeah big big obstacles for the kids yeah
sure but i i also have like a walk like
a big fridge for other things yeah
like no i like
i'm one of those prep i like to have
like this big fridge with all food in it
and you can walk you gotta walk okay
wait did you say you're a prepper like a
doomsday president no no no i just like
to have
food ready to go wow really
that's pretty good yeah water food
everything
i like it yeah that's really yeah listen
when they're pandemic you couldn't even
go to store
groceries you're ready with meatballs
guys we're good [ __ ] up the girls invite
people for [ __ ] dinner
toilet paper really check this out
oh you got it all you have to do oh yeah
really yeah
yeah it does it right man oh yeah
stocked up and ready to go how long
could you last in your place
if everything's shut down you're
cruising for what months
a year years as far as food and water
lose everything like that
a long time yeah pretty good yeah i
would say a long time i even have i have
my own
i have my own power to my own generator
something goes wrong this guy's off the
grid i love it
if something goes wrong that well i
could i mean as long if i could fill it
up again i can go a month without
any power really something goes wrong i
got about 38 minutes
[Laughter]
and i'm [ __ ] dead if i can't find the
cvs to get my next year
i'm in trouble i need an aspirin today
but i'm i'm super fanatical with that i
love it now where does that come from i
don't know
my dad was very ocd and he was like
always be prepared
always be prepared about that and he
kind of put it in my head you know
whenever i drive to a place as soon as i
get there i fill it up the car will be
really
yeah and you don't get hemmed up in a
bad situation you know what get moving
you can get moving
you know what i've done that and my dad
gave me that advice and it saved me two
or three times
really two or three times where i got
somewhere and there was like uh in l.a
an earthquake uh you know one of those
earthquakes sandy
where you go oh everybody's at the pump
lines you just go
[ __ ] me dean martin playing on the radio
the subway see you later
losers yeah and my son my son is
like me because he looked at me he goes
you were right dad i said all right
that's why i got to get that's why i got
the guess yeah
so i mean saying like okay so like let's
say right now you drove down to atlantic
city you drive down legacy the first
thing you're doing
is filling up the car drop
you have a daily driver or for like no i
i have them whatever i want
yeah yeah yeah yeah i would say do you
still drive though do you like to drive
i like to drive
so if you go to gristiti's you might hop
in the car oh yeah if i go to grastitis
i drive yeah
no if i come to the city he drove you
down today he drove me down today yeah
he's waiting outside yes that's [ __ ]
classy dude
yeah yeah but if i but if i if i go to
receipt i go myself yeah
i like doing that now is he just a
driver or a little bit more
at least a little more yeah yeah so you
come up here and smack us around
i like to i i hire i have two guys that
work for me they're ex-policemen
retired yes they got steel on them is
what he's saying
i said they heard
it can regulate problems if need be
chad's ain't rolling around with two
goons
these are these are these kind of walk
around with one of my old friends that i
got to protect him
they have certain negotiation skills
yeah no they're they're they're
trying to do policemen and they're
terrific yeah that's the way to do it
what situation would you take them with
you whenever like are they downstairs
now
who's downstairs right now holy [ __ ]
that's [ __ ]
awesome yeah toby do something stupid so
you got to get working
get them up here [ __ ]
have you tune you up a bit
holy shine now we're getting into it
this is what i like i love it guys all
class i
love you're you're breaking i mean like
we had chrissy d oh christie
he's an animal he's a nice guy he was
classy but i mean he's yeah you see the
house he rented into l.a
yeah it's a [ __ ] hearst castle i know
he's new money he's new money
incredible yeah yeah yeah it's great now
is that something you'd be yelling at
him for
or you know like live it up and enjoy it
i think he's a smart guy but i just
always said you know
always try to live a little under your
immediately yeah yeah of course
we're starting to make a couple of bucks
and that's where we're having to
readjust from
these struggling comments oh okay but
just yeah
see you could buy things when you start
making money but
it's it's to keep it and maintain it
that's the problem yeah yeah
yeah buying it is not a problem you know
it's keeping you smart
it's keeping it it's like buying a horse
and then it's like 30 grand defeated
every year did you have exactly
did you have that i know it was like a
lot of small moves and like even like
bronx tell you you were building up to
it over over like four or five or six
years from
89 to when it when it came out did you
have one big check that you splurged on
something was it was there like
what was the first big buy yeah i could
you want me to tell you the story about
that
yeah yeah you got damn right we do okay
i'm waiting for it i make the deal
with the narrow the deal's done right
i'm sitting in my apartment
now uh i got some money i got a few
dollars
can we ask what that number was like
from the middle of the first check
yeah well what so what was the deal with
deniro were you guys going to split the
back end
no i i could tell you what i got a i got
paid a million and a half dollars
for those to write it and everything
nice so you got over you got you
got over what i wanted yeah and to
[ __ ] be close
yeah chaz is playing [ __ ] chess over
here it's because of dinero i mean i i
i owe bob so much and we're best friends
and
he's the one who's crazy i know bobby
[Laughter]
his girlfriend's calling bobby friends
call him fred his real friend's call
baba b
family calls him robert [ __ ] is
calling bobby
okay so um uh i'm
sitting there my apartment i got a
better apartment it wasn't great but it
was better
and i'm on laurel canyon and i'm with my
friend dayton cali
he's a wonderful actor really a great
actor and he's been on many shows if you
see his face you know he is
he's been on deadwood in a bunch of
shows and it's me and him we're working
on a scene for
the theater where i'm from the acting
place where i
developed the problems too we're going
back and forth sitting on it
now i'm i knew the deal was closed i'm
waiting for the check right
i get a knock on the door here we go
again every time that [ __ ] door
the guy goes uh how are you doing chad
he was he worked the way mars he goes
he goes you want to sign this i said
okay so i think it's
something i have to sign for i don't
know which i have no idea because they
didn't say the check's coming right
they didn't say nothing to me so
this [ __ ] story guys i'm telling you
i'm writing my
i'm this is going to be i'm writing a
movie about how this whole thing
happened oh i can't i can't
i cannot wait i go like this i go yeah
dayton so yeah we'll get that other
scene together and we go
i go like this i go start pulling it
back and [ __ ]
i got no i got a few dollars now maybe
maybe i got three or four thousand in
the bank
no don't good maybe so yeah it's great
for actually like working actor yeah
which i got
what she led to me let me so i'm looking
and i go
i go hey dane i said i just got a check
for fifty thousand dollars he goes fifty
thousand dollars he goes that's
impossible
wait i said i don't know maybe it's a
payment for the bronx tale he stands
there because let me see that he stands
up
he leans over my shoulder my eyes are
like crushed because
i can't see he goes
he goes chaz that's 500
[Laughter]
so i go like this he says that's 500
000.
the brain can't process the zeros it's
never seen it i couldn't process this
sure so i go like this i go i sit down
i sit down in the ottoman he sits down
on the couch just like that
and we don't say a [ __ ] word for
three minutes
not one god word man i'm like this
and tears start rolling down my [ __ ]
eyes
right and i get up and i go holy [ __ ]
five hundred thousand dollars i go
[ __ ] so i go dayton so i take a few deep
breaths i'm getting nervous now i'm
thinking about it i take a few deep
breaths and i go
you know what dayton the first thing i'm
going to buy with this [ __ ] money
i said we're going to the [ __ ] uh the
name of the store i wish i could
remember the names it was like
a big department store i said because i
saw my vacuum cleaner to pay my electric
bill
pissed me off and i never forgot that
and i said i'm gonna go there and i'm
gonna buy the best
[ __ ] vacuum cleaner they got so my
friend dayton goes
hey chad you know just like neighborhood
guys hey i need one
call your mother yeah she's getting one
you're gay you can what i'm about to
tell you you can't make this [ __ ] up
my mother and father if i'm lying to you
if i'm exaggerating to you sure he goes
i go come on we go to this [ __ ] store
i wish i could remember the name of it
we walk in
so i got a credit card so i go shoot me
sir i want the best
vacuum cleaners you have how do you go
my friend goes they got suits on
my friend right
so we go we go
guy goes like this he's showing us the
best i go excuse me
you know what i said is this the best he
goes well there's a
there's another one he goes he goes but
that's professional you don't need it i
said listen to me
it's my [ __ ] money i want the best
one yeah
and he goes my friend dane's going
didn't you hear what the man said
[Laughter]
so we get we get the two [ __ ] vacuum
cleaners we buy them
right so as we're waiting for them as
we're waiting for them
i got the check folded up in my [ __ ]
pocket
as we're waiting for them i hear
i had glass breaking i said what the
[ __ ]
it's like okay what is that i hear i
hear people yelling
so i go leaning or i go i go to the end
of the aisle and i lean over and i look
there's two guys with ski masks on with
hammers and they're breaking the glass
taking the jewelry out
and also as i turn around i go what the
and the guy was
with a gun he was watching over them
turns to me and my friend dayton goes
eat the [ __ ] floor [ __ ] and i
went
and i lay on the floor yeah [ __ ] i lay
on the floor he lays on the floor
everybody's laying on the floor and the
bell is going off right
and i turn to date and i go dayton i
ain't [ __ ] dying
not now yeah i just i just i just got
[ __ ] paid
500 000 i just got a brand new vacuum
cleaner and a brick
right right doing them right two of them
so i said come on
so i said let's get so we crawl around
to the other side of the [ __ ] aisle
and because everybody was everybody was
frozen yeah they didn't move
but i don't want to sound like a tough
guy but i've had guns pulled on me
before
i'm like i'm getting the [ __ ] out of
here because i am not going to be
hostage
because i can see it now the bells are
ringing the cops are on their way
yeah and they were rushing these guys i
gotta i see these two old women
they're standing there i grabbed one i
go dang get her and we kicked the
[ __ ] door open that rang bella two
and we pull out and me and him took off
damn damn
now we had to go back to the [ __ ]
fire
same day and then you went back
[ __ ] no need that man needs a vacuum
cleaner and we have my back still have
that [ __ ] vacuum
do you
[Music]
that's fantastic so that was your first
big thing it was it was a vacuum cleaner
that was my first if that ain't glass i
don't know what it is yeah
a lot of guys blow it on this and that
no no no don't bought a new car oh
what was a legend a legend a legend a
legend yeah that would they don't make
it yeah it was a
acura accurate legend okay okay okay
good card i got you
acker's a nice card then i gave it to my
father then i bought myself a really
like a mercedes oh bmw was first before
the mercedes yeah
classic class move man um
all right i got another one here if
you're going out to uh you're going to a
friend's house for dinner right
yes uh you're taking a bottle of wine
how much you dropping on that bottle of
wine
oh you're going low ball like the 13
ball you're going high what are you
doing
the minimum a minimum would be 50.
on the top end would be 150. nice do you
then how do you delineate who gets the
150 who gets the 50.
is it how close you are to them well how
i know
when i go to their house what they're
serving me sure like you know if i know
i go you know i go to bob's house it's
yeah you can't be getting a 50
bottle i'm getting i'm getting a really
good one yeah okay
because just because he knows really
good ones he knows because he's a
connoisseur
right one of my friends i go i'm still
going to give him a good why because
he'll break my [ __ ]
yeah it was [ __ ] this thing yeah yeah
you got me sutter homes bob's house i
invited you
for the [ __ ] wine
yeah one job chad you know the problem
is
there's good in bed the problem is and
you guys you'll see
you'll know you'll find out when you i
don't know you probably get it now when
you're all having dinner somewhere at a
restaurant
the check comes well this is another
question i wanted that they just they
just sit there
because they assume chad is going to
take care of that which i do
yeah yeah and that's fine yeah i don't
mind that but
say you're going out with another group
you know other successful actor friend
how do you chop it up then is there a
conversation someone just grab it
or do you sit there and like i have the
penny and the dessert no we don't go
okay who ate the shrimp
[Laughter]
who ate the shrimp i didn't have a coke
so one of you would pay rather than
split it yeah no we wouldn't split it
okay
yeah like imagine him and [ __ ]
like him and then he wrote throwing up
credit cards
that's so funny and i'd ask you about
tipping but i know you're a good tipper
because you were actually one of the
last two yeah
i ever waited on a couple years ago yes
it was you and your son and it was that
yeah it was at a burger place in the
west village
his last day of work it was the last day
that i was working there was the last
time i ever waited tables
i always leave a good tip it did me very
well yes i it's
because i uh i i look at it and i told
my son that i said
that it means more to them than it is
a few boxes i i even think of that
actually that extra 20 whatever
and normally i wouldn't really think
that but since it was you
i was like i hope to god that he tips me
well just because everything that i
believe in him
would then come true and and you did you
came through
yes i also finished your burger i didn't
want to tell you
i didn't you had like a bacon blue
cheeseburger and you cut it in half and
didn't finish it
so i ate the rest of it i figured hey
this is as good as it's going to get i'm
waiting
i didn't know how to interview him in
two years everything you do in your life
foley does the opposite yeah except for
tipping i'm a good dipper too
good you gotta be um what kind of
cologne do you like to wear
um i i i'm trying to take the cologne
that i wear now
um i like to try different colognes i
don't uh i forgot the name of it damn it
i just can't think of the name
what about back in the day were you ever
like a brute old spice kind of guy
english leather never even the way he
said no he wasn't getting there
canoe what about canoe no no canoe can
it was big
no it was it was big i just didn't like
uh i like the more of a subtle stuff you
know the more designer stuff like
you know the calvin klein or something
like that
this guy's classy yeah um at home do you
keep your butter
on the counter or in the fridge in the
fridge
[Music]
i'm sorry there's one in the one in the
fridge and one in the counter because
some people like it smooth my wife keeps
it
there's two i mean come on you think
he's not he's he's got both for
everybody guys covering his basement
just realize that my wife keeps it out
and i keep it again i
i need you to know that you've made
everyone else we've had some of the
biggest comedians in the world on the
show
you've made them all look homeless yeah
yeah that's also i mean obviously it's
it's uh it's an italian thing too
italians are very put together
pride of it's like a very everything's
very calculated
very very very meticulous and i and my
wife is like really everything has to be
like beautiful yeah like if you if you
some if we have a guest over the house
the next day you'll wake up
and you come down in the kitchen you'll
think it's the four seasons oh
pancakes and french toast and jam and
these beautiful jars
she does it nicely she does it she does
it right that's awesome
you know she does it right now this
might be a silly question but do you
have a guy right now
to make custom suits for you you're a
custom suit guy i would assume yeah how
many
what's the ballpark number on suture you
think you got but but there's a better
question for that go ahead and ask me
how many shoots i have yeah how many
half probably 60.
okay but ask me how many i paid for how
many did you paid for
two why
because you go to places and they want
you to wear that yeah famously out they
get
yeah here what do you wear i can't say
that i that i i might have paid two or
three
i might have paid for them myself two or
three yeah but most of them
i have all the clothes and the suits
from all of my movies
really everything everything now you
said something you put in the contract
you just kind of last they just put that
contract because they they don't want it
anymore yeah they got hip to it
uh yeah cause i i tried to steal a jack
i was on gotham once i tried to steal a
jacket
i didn't even make it off the driveway
they were all over i have i have a
huge sheet of closet uh
and i have from bronx tale
brocksdale oscar usual suspects all
sealed in plastic
with the title and name on the thing
fantastic sonny suits for something else
so that was like
i learned that from from bob he's the
one who taught me what take the wardrobe
take the wardrobe really because he just
sold his wall
i think he just gave it to a museum in
dallas oh yeah
but it's it's worth you know for my
children it's a legacy
yeah of course the [ __ ] joshua the suit
sold for half a million dollars
the white suit from time to time yeah
yeah okay
that's pretty good what could you sell
your suit for you
half a ham sandwich no mustard
how do you feel about hawaiian pizza
when was the last time you were at an
applebee's a tj of fridays or an olive
garden yeah i was going to ask you have
you ever eaten an olive garden
i'm trying to think maybe years ago no
no no
i think it would be so funny if you went
like denier and you were like all just
popped into an olive garden one night
i don't know how staunch you are with
this but is there any circumstances
at the pormentary household that there
would be a
jar of spaghetti sauce
a jar of sauce a jar of sauce like if
you're making pasta
i'm trying to think if my wife ever had
something in a
you pinch you've got a garage full of
doomsday breakfast
yeah no way there's chocolate i have
cases of
san jose tomato tomatoes of course oh no
no i i want you to understand that i was
saying not that not that it's crazy that
you don't have it
yeah it's so awesome that you have
everything to make it to make actually
never have the jar is so awesome no i
have we have cases of the
of the tomatoes and i have a guy who
has fresh tomatoes and gets it and then
we have jaws sealed
so i can go either way with the cans or
have that and just use that so there's
not going to be a bottle of classico in
the pantry at your house
no pretty good no oh i love it
um all right this one this is one we did
with chrissy d
uh you're you're going as a guest to a
wedding what are you dropping at the
wedding
not like someone that's close but not
close you know
i'm dropping a good vote yeah yeah you
got it right you got it you gotta
yeah a grand what are we talking about
uh
if it's a friend a grant yeah friend's
kid
let's say a grant a grant cash not a
cheque not cash no a cash
hundreds
[Music]
[Laughter]
just with the answers to the question
the way i literally just saw my head
jazz vomiter just looked definitely said
always hundreds
like that's not you know you go to a
wedding they invite you what are you
gonna do all right let's give a hundred
each
yeah i get it of course it's very
expensive to get married i know
yeah and you know what if my friend's
son or daughter you know yeah
yeah yeah absolutely [ __ ] class act
man
classy all the way hmm here's one
good you go to the beach you guys are
great
i know what chrissy kept saying to me
you're gonna love these guys you're
gonna love this show
you go to the beach right right uh are
you uh sitting close to the to the water
guy
or are you sitting close to the to the
dunes guy or somewhere in the middle
there is it there is a classy and a
trashy answer i just want to see i'm not
by the water i can tell you that
okay yeah i'm not by the water that's it
i'm i'm back
where usually oh god
i try to get a house to rent a house
that's right by the water
so if i feel like sitting on my deck and
my kids
and my wife go to the water they can and
something but then they'll come back and
they'll just stay on the deck
nice now the trashy version if you go
close to the shoreline to the water
you're garbage yeah yeah they're always
the garbage half in the water
one of them's going to happen
trash you sit back on the beach
you sit back on the beach like a
gentleman that's coming in they're
dropping hot dogs
oh
will you will you go local for vacation
sometimes or is it always going to be
like uh
south of france or something like that
like will you go down to the jersey
shore or anything
i've rented houses on the jersey street
yes yes i've rented houses
uh where do you go on the jersey shore
like you know love ladies
um it ain't gonna be wildwood
you can you can rent you can we need to
go to the hamptons yeah oh we go to the
jersey shore which is uh
long beach island yeah very close
uh you know right by the water it's
beautiful yeah it's beautiful jersey
shore is very underrated jersey show is
very underrated it's very beautiful yeah
absolutely very nice i like it hamptons
glass very classy yeah the hamptons is
great too yeah
um have you ever been on a cruise never
[Laughter]
and i've been offered to go on cruises
i'm sure for
free yeah i'm sure for free and i could
stay at the captain's table
and eat it i can't go i just
you cannot trap me there like that you
know and you gotta come and go
if the beginning of the pandemic didn't
teach anybody anything no don't ever go
on a cruise
i just can't be locked into this this is
it you're on you're not getting old
yeah no it's not for me sorry if
somebody has a cold everybody gets it
yeah i don't know and you're quarantined
on that thing it's not for me i can't do
it no
never cruise never do you fall asleep
watching tv
uh sometimes i do
okay do you sleep with a fan next to the
bed on you no
okay no fair enough
um let's see another big one on the show
uh is do you brush your teeth in the
shower
no no yeah no a man of his hair i don't
know he kind of paused
no i'm thinking i'm trying to make sure
if i ever did that no no no not again
come on
chazz ain't brushing his teeth i'm not
going to brush my teeth in the tower do
you drink the coffee in the hotel room
the little coffee maker will you make
that
i don't drink coffee okay
what's your cocktail of choice are you a
wine guy
wine red white what do you both both
dependent on the mood and the meal baby
did you ever collect any of the
following
swords which words was like a sword
oh sure yeah you really pronounced the w
in
[Laughter]
no chinese stars no what about beanie
babies
no okay i mean what the [ __ ] you're
going to insult us like that
i just wanted to be sure i'm sorry i'm
just trying to get [ __ ] pissed off
get [ __ ] steve out of that truck
bring it up guys we're going great
i got to call bobby lamb chops
that's his name bobby lambchop i've
got's the best name in the world
that's so good bobby lamb chop it's
intimidating but also he might be a
sweet guy
you know what i mean when he gets to
know him he's a real sweet guy yeah he's
not bashing
your brains into the sidewalk uh man
i think i only got one more that i want
to reserve for you
which is the dinner the dinner yeah what
do you drink
oh growing up or now
growing up or now or now do you ever
have milk with dinner
never no never never not even growing up
never nice plate nice plate of lasagna
have a nice glass of melon
really i mean people actually do that
some italians do
a lot of it their italians do it yeah
yeah he would it was if there's
they did it a lot in the sopranos he
would come home and open up a thing and
he'd have a big glass of milk and he'd
be eating like cold lasagna or whatever
i don't get it i the half the population
milk with dinner it's wild i'm sorry i
i never yeah it's crazy your kids i
assume not either
never not milk
not milk no man
all right the last question yeah is it
okay to get a toothpick when you're
walking out of the restaurant
i i i don't do that no no i i'm not that
i'm saying it's bad
yeah you're just not a yeah i'm just not
into picking my teeth
yeah things like that in public in
public yeah this guy's
this is books clothes yeah it's as
classy as she gets 100
class class even the way you poured the
pellegrino that's classy
we apologize for the solo cups yeah we
wanted to get something we got to keep
it on brand a little bit though you got
you got the pellegrino out of a plastic
cup
you could have a waterfall listen most
people don't even get a water
you got a pellegrino i was like 350.
i'm sending chrissy d a receipt for that
gang what an absolute
unbelievable episode uh chas palmitary
thank you so much
is there anything you want the folks out
there to know that you have coming up
other than
yeah well i want to make sure that
people go to my new podcast
josh commentary show it's on spotify on
youtube
it's just fantastic fantastic thank you
very much i i talk about acting writing
directing it's like a master class
that's funny with funny stories of
course
and i talk about neighborhood logic and
that's really the big thing is that
uh godfather of holland premieres april
18th
and if people excuse me you want to see
my one-man show
they can go on chasepalmeteri.net and my
whole schedule for this year
and next year the touring where i will
be
and they can go to my line store and get
anything all those
uh uh like old uh uh uh
posters that i had from my original
bronx tales show if they want to
purchase that fantastic yeah
absolutely unbelievable thank you so
much kippy what do you got for them just
as always please make sure you review
subscribe on itunes
subscribe on youtube for full video and
then patreon.com and i'm at kevinryan
comedy on all social media
absolutely fantastic episode guys thank
you so much we love you and we'll see
you next week